one of this year's breakout independent
movies is Britney runs a marathon which
Amazon bought for 14 million dollars
after a bidding war described by variety
as a whip-smart comedy with real
emotional depth in won the audience
award in the u.s. dramatic category at
Sundance this year
Gillian Bell stars as Britney a
twenty-something New Yorker who tries to
get her life together by taking up
running after a rude awakening at the
doctor's office what brings in today I
have a hard time focusing I get enough
sleep every night how much is enough six
to eight hours oh way more than that
that's not the problem but I had a
friend who was also just very out of it
and she was prescribed um Oh what is it
adderall and now she's very alert you
know some people abused that or all the
recreational purposes what that's crazy
that's true I'm sorry you have to deal
well I do yeah all the time
what Jillian Bella is also an executive
producer on the movie Jillian good
morning good morning thank you for
welcome thanks for in here
congratulation on the film when you
first read like the first ten pages of
the script you weren't so sure you
wanted to play this role no I was
terrified my manager sent it to me and
she said the first 10 pages you're gonna
think oh this is a little scary this
might feel a little too real for you but
I think just keep reading because the
script is beautiful and it's got a great
message and I fell in love with it I was
crying I was laughing and when I
finished I sort of thought oh I I want
to play her desperately and I hope
they'll let me I'll be very protective
of her the next one after the doctor II
says oh by the way you need to lose 55
pounds
Britney says so you want me to lose a
small Siberian Husky off of my body yes
I mean and there's great scenes in the
movie with her getting on the scale you
getting on the scale you actually lost
weight for them or did you actually lose
weight for the movie
I lost 40 pounds I there were parts of
the script that I couldn't quite connect
to because I hadn't experienced it
myself and I thought well I obviously
have to start running there's a lot of
running in this film and I've been a
runner no not a runner by nature but I
decided said I'm a runner I have two
legs everyone gave me a runner they have
two legs but yeah for me it was it was a
new experience but I decided I wanted to
sort of take on the physical journey
because I thought it would connect me to
the character more so speaking of the
character this is based on a real person
a real Brittany has she seen it and if
so had it to react she's seen it she's
been involved since the beginning it's
basically a love letter to her from Paul
Downs Claes oh the writer/director
it's his best friend it's his best
friend and he just wrote this movie was
so inspired by her it was loosely based
on her life story and so yeah she was
involved in obviously seeing different
drafts of it and then coming and seeing
us shoot and and seeing different edits
and it's called Brittany runs a marathon
but it's so much more than running it's
so much more than a movie about running
about losing weight Brittany went
through a transformation can you talk a
little bit about her transformation and
did you go through a transformation
doing this movie I definitely do I felt
like it would either be something that
was very therapeutic or I would spiral
out I was hoping for the first and and
it made me examine the way I thought
about myself how you thought about how I
thought about myself how I talked about
myself you know sometimes always making
the first joke hoping that someone else
wouldn't say something hurtful and and
it just made me think you know I'm I
deserve better than that and Brittany
deserves better than that did you make
those that journey did it make you want
to run a marathon no no I do enjoy
running but there's a difference between
running a couple of miles and running
26.2 miles I love you actually shot this
at the New York City Marathon we did get
to shoot there we were the first film
crew that got to shoot there people
thought it was a documentary they
thought you were really running I think
they thought I was really running and if
anyone was trying to like help me along
during during parts I didn't want
tell them no I'm acting curse makeup
artist over here leave me alone yeah you
know I thought it was so sweet it was
such an inspiring thing to be around the
runner and she also has some moments
where she's just really not a nice
person
yeah I think that yeah I think that's
interesting I think it's great because
you know what I like her even when she
was just well you want to I think that's
but Paul did a beautiful job of just
making a very layered human being
usually my character in this movie kind
of plays a sidekick and comes in and
encourages the lead and then says a
funny line and leaves and and this is a
different kind of story we've got to let
her go to her morning run I think thank
you very much for being always must be
nice to have a bidding war though in
Sunday yeah that's gotta be a cat it's a
little bit Madame executive producer
brunette runs the marathon will be
available in select theaters August 23rd